this is a shot of Charlize Theron in
bombshell yes that is actually Charlize
Theron who was nominated for an Oscar
for her performance as former Fox News
anchor megyn kelly put the two
side-by-side and it's extremely
difficult to tell the difference
viewers were certainly fooled this
transformation was a triumph and makeup
and prosthesis especially when
considering the fact that the film's
prosthetic makeup designer Kazuhiro said
that turning an actor into a real person
can be the most difficult task a makeup
artist faces as the audience already has
an image in their head of what that
person should look like so what made
this especially difficult and why was
getting a cast of the inside of Charlize
Theron Snow's a key part of the process
Kazuhiro is no stranger to turning
actors into real people he won the Best
Makeup Oscar for 2017 s darkest hour in
which he made Gary Oldman look exactly
like Winston Churchill for bombshell he
worked with makeup department head
Vivien Baker and hair stylist and Morgan
the trio received an Oscar nomination
for their work on the film the biggest
challenges they faced the actors had to
look almost exactly like the people they
were portraying and the makeup and
prosthesis had to be created in a very
short amount of time as they only had
six weeks of pre-production first hero
Baker and their team spent months
watching Fox news clips to get the best
possible understanding of Kelly's look
and style
then once the actors were cast hero did
a 3d body scan and life cast this helped
him directly compare the physical
features of the actors and the figures
they were being transformed into then he
made a mold of each life cast and
created the skin like prosthesis based
off of those molds the prosthesis were
made with medical grade silicone and
attached to the actors faces with strong
medical glue these prosthesis had to be
applied to Theron every day a process
that usually took close to three hours
Theron did wear prosthetic pieces but
makeup products also helped alter the
way her face looks according to Baker
the two women have very differently
shaped eyes getting the eyes right was
essential and turning Theron into Kelly
fake eyelashes were used to reshape
their ins eyes instead of using
inflexible lash strips faker opted for
lash a Phi gossamer z' which are fake
eyelashes that come in pieces while a
normal lash strip would just sit on the
lash line
these lash pieces could be placed with
more freedom Baker use the pieces to
manipulate the weight of the lash line
which reshaped and resized their ins
eyes meanwhile Theron also wore colored
contact lenses because Kelly's eyes are
a darker shade of blue
the eyes are topped off with prosthetic
eyelid pieces since they're in his
bigger eyes and what Shiro said were
more open eyelids than Kelly these
pieces helped close that gap the eyelids
were the most difficult prosthesis to
create during an initial makeup test
they're in a difficulty blinking while
wearing them according to hero this can
happen if you apply too much glue as the
skin around the eyes is especially
sensitive aside from the eyelids the
actors had to overcome several other
obstacles posed by the prosthesis for
example these nose pieces the biggest
difference between thier ins and Kelly's
noses were the nostrils and tips a full
nose prosthesis was not necessary though
instead hero created nose plugs to widen
the holes and a nose tip which made
their ins nose more up turned like
Kelly's to make the plugs hero actually
took a cast of the inside of ferren's
nose he then scanned the cast created
the plugs in a program called ZBrush and
then 3d printed them it took three to
five attempts for the makeup team to get
the plugs right why because if the plugs
were too big they could actually impact
her voice in the end 40 pairs were
printed for the duration of filming each
plug had a handle on it so Hiro could
easily pull them in and out with
tweezers as you can see here the nostril
with the plug is wider than the one with
no plug Hiro did use more traditional
prosthesis
to reshape certain parts of ferren's
face the makeup team found that Kelly
had a more angular face than Theron so
they gave their in a jaw piece that
helped create this look to further to
find the angular and square appearance
Theron also wore a fake chin one final
observation was that Theron had a much
higher forehead than Kelly you can't
really create a prosthesis to make
somebody's head lower so he deferred to
the hair department their decision
bring Farren's hairline down Theron wore
several wigs in the movie including one
with long hair and one with short hair
according to Morgan lowering the
hairline best health gift there in a
quote heart-shaped face like Kelly's but
before Theron was fully camera-ready the
team also had to apply beauty makeup on
top of the prosthesis now this is never
easy to do but they also had to apply
extra makeup to her to make her look
like an anchor who is going on live
television plus beauty makeup doesn't
easily stick to prosthesis and is prone
to come off so Baker mix the foundation
with face mist and then airbrushed it on
which ensured that all the makeup stuff
to the prosthesis for long shoot days it
worked and as you can see here Theron
was even able to apply some of her own
makeup while getting ready and for a few
instances when the makeup did start to
fall apart on set the film with lighter
touch up the makeup digitally that way
they wouldn't have to apply makeup all
over again themselves it was a handy way
to save time and money on set yet
getting the makeup to stick isn't the
only challenging part of acting with
prosthesis there's a risk of them
limiting an actor's performance which
could have happened to Theron if the
makeup team had added even more pieces
to her face
to avoid restricting the performances
Hiro limited the use of prosthesis
whenever he could put all these features
together the forehead the hair the chin
the tip of the nose the nostrils the
eyelids the eyes and the makeup that
went on top of it and you have Megan
Kelly so in the end
just how realistic did it all turn out
well according to director Jay Roach it
looks so realistic that the film's
lawyers made them add a disclaimer at
the start of the movie clarifying that
any non archival footage was actually an
actor and not the person they were
portraying
[Music]